comment ça va j'aime pas qu'on vous
suive
il ya deux choses qui vont se passer mon
pardon d'abord le téléphone qui l'a
façonné ensuite ses menottes seront vos
poignets vous êtes qui nom de dieu celui
que vous n'attendiez pas
ans augmente pourquoi vous avez
raccroché il ya sept grosses marques de
coups là sur le dessus il paraît que
vous avez fait c'est avec la tête des
cultures j'ai besoin de votre aide
ils ont tué des hommes
des soldats qui étaient sous vos ordres
je sais ce que tu as fait
tu aurais dû rester en dehors de ça vous
m'avez suivi jusqu'ici c'est pas mal un
sérieux messieurs c'est moi qui me fais
des idées aux salaires de vous réjouir
vous avez une façon assez particulière
de dire merci
il sent pas très bien je vous conseille
celle là
est ce qui s'est passé la bague à un
seul mec les atouts c'est aller à l'onu
il est encore dedans tournez vous
monsieur montrez moi vos mains doucement
coups et blessures c'est un crime dans
notre état monsieur reacher parce qu'il
est mal noté au trot il ya deux choses
qui vont se passer dans les 90 secondes
demande pardon d'abord le téléphone
qu'il avait sonné ensuite ces menottes
seront vos poignets quand vous irez en
prison la papa est bâtie dans voilà une
prédiction qui me laisse sans voix
monsieur rituel
il va pas s'arrêter de sonner
merci de nous avoir fait rire vous venez
quand à washington j'aurais pas de
bouger toutes ses décorations
vous êtes une légende on se demande
pourquoi vous avez raccroché je me suis
levé un matin uniforme à l'est plus
jack reacher pour le majeur turner de
michael turner a été arrêté on l'accuse
de quoi d'espionnage c'est un coup monté
il en sait beaucoup ce rituel comment ça
va j'aime pas que mou suivent tu te
croient invincibles c'est ça c'est ça
et si j'étais un chum bras pour te
massacrer avec faudra pas m'en vouloir
rich à fond là pour vous éliminer
mes hommes ont été tués par l'un des
nôtres c'est plus gros que je
n'imaginais ça vous est déjà arrivé de
perdre un beau gars
qu'un homme nord
vous croyez au dessus de la loire
mais je suis pas la loi
devriez-vous mettre à courir parce que
je vais me mettre en chasse et quand je
vous trouverai je vous tuerai tous
c'est la coupe de cheveux vous avez tous
le même coiffeur